alright guys so in this tutorial series
we're going to be creating an Evernote
clone and it's going to be almost a
fully functional Evernote clone there's
going to be certain features that were
not going to be implementing in this
tutorial such as users although I do
have another video previous video that I
created where we do go over that so if
you'd like to learn more about that
there is a link in the description below
for that video series but in this video
we're just going to focus on Evernote
we're gonna be using firebase and we're
going to be using a library called a
react quill so I think it's time for us
to go ahead and demonstrate what it is
we're going to be making in this app so
I can come over here and click new note
and enter a new title call it new note I
submitted the note and as you can see it
selects it automatically and over here
on the right we have a text editor and
we can edit the title I'll just call it
like new Note 2 and then I can come down
here you can see it updated live and I
can go heading 1 this is a header and
again you can see it updates live over
here and so I can you know just this is
some more text you know just a show that
we can have different sized texts and
everything great another note we'll just
say test list and come in here and
create a list you know 1 2 3 so you can
see we can create lists so we can make
text bold and it updates live over here
and I can go through and select each
note I can also delete my notes and it
says are you sure you want to delete
note - I'll click yes and it goes ahead
and selects the previous one
automatically for me and I'll delete
this one as well and that is what we're
gonna be making in this tutorial series
so I'll come over to here to firebase
you're gonna want to go to consult
firebase google.com make sure you create
a firebase account you can just go to
firebase create an account and once you
have the account go to consult firebase
google.com and you'll be presented with
this go ahead and click Add project and
inside of here we'll just call it
Evernote clone and make sure you check
this box and this box and click create
project once that finishes go ahead and
click continue and you'll see this
dashboard screen over here on the left
click database now
firebase has two different types of
databases they have cloud fire store and
the real time database real time
database is their older original
database and fire store is their newer
database so that's what we're going to
be using when you click create database
just make sure you click it under cloud
fire store and not real time database so
let's go ahead and click create database
go ahead and start it in the test mode
click Next
go ahead and click the select the
location nearest you and then done and
then wait for that to finish once that
finishes you'll be brought to this
screen right here this is going to be
basically a data table that shows a
visual representation of your data
inside of the database now if I click
this rules area here you can see that
it's very similar to JavaScript it's a
little different but it's got similar
syntax and you can see here it says
allow read write and what that's saying
is you can both read and write from this
no matter what if you're not
authenticated that it doesn't matter who
you are or any of that you can read and
write to this database so in a
production environment you're not going
to want to have this you're gonna want
to have very strict access rules and
you're going to want to set up
authentication for your app but we're
not going to be doing any of this in
this tutorial I do have a video where I
do go over autant ocation creating login
forms and signup forms all through
firebase I will include a link in the
description for you to watch that
tutorial series which includes those
topics but we're not going to go over
that in this particular video so just
keep that in mind and so when we use and
we setup our firebase within the app
itself we're going to be exposing our
API key so if anybody were to get a hold
of that they could just use your your
firebase so what I do is I delete my key
once I'm done with the tutorial series
or just don't show anybody your API key
either to either of those you'll be fine
just make sure you don't give away your
API key to anybody so now that that is
now that that's been said we can go to
project overview here and then you go
ahead and click this this little icon
right here that looks like to HTML
brackets
when you click that just name this
Evernote tutorial leave this unchecked
and click register app and then once
that finishes go ahead and I want you to
copy this object right here don't
include the script tags just copy what's
inside of here and actually you don't
have to copy right now we'll just keep
this in mind keep this window open keep
this right here and we'll get back to
this shortly let's go ahead and install
all of our dependencies for the project
first and then we'll paste this into our
application so we will be using create
react app in order to initialize the
react application project so go ahead
and go to this link I will include it in
the description so once you get to this
link you'll see instructions on how to
install create rack react app it's
extremely simple and it is a facebook
tutorial on how to do it it's very very
short very very simple go ahead and
install that and once you do have that
installed open up your terminal window
I'm gonna be using windows you can use
any terminal window from either Linux
Mac or Windows to follow along but let
me increase the font size of this really
quick so you can see all of this okay
that should be quite a bit better for
you so go ahead and navigate to wherever
you want your project to be so I'm gonna
be inside of my Documents folder or
actually Dropbox so go ahead and just
navigate to wherever you want your
project to be and I'm gonna say create
react app just like that and then you're
gonna want to put the name of the app so
I'm gonna say evernote evernote tutorial
and then when you click enter it's going
to actually go ahead and install this
this project directory tree that's
basically ready for you to get started
on react so let's go ahead and wait for
this to finish okay so once that
finishes we're gonna want to go ahead
and install our first dependency we're
going to be using material UI for this
which is going to be a library that
allows us to make styling very easy it's
going to handle a lot of things it just
includes react components that we can
use that makes things look pretty by
default essentially so that we can focus
solely on react and not have to worry
about writing a ton of CSS
so let's go ahead and start we're gonna
say npm install at material - UI the
slash core so go ahead and install that
and once that's done go ahead and do NPM
install at material - UI / icons and
this is gonna give us a ton of icons to
be able to use which I think we're only
gonna be using two icons the trashcan
for delete and the pencil and paper for
edit so go ahead and wait for that to
finish okay
and for our text editor we'll be using a
react quill which is an open source
library so we will say npm install react
- quill q UI ll go ahead and install
that and finally we're gonna go ahead
and install firebase so npm npm install
firebase so let that finish really quick
alright so that's gonna be all of our
dependencies here so i'm gonna go ahead
and clear my console and actually just
type in npm space start to go ahead and
get react up and running just to make
sure everything is running smoothly so
once this pops up i'll also go ahead and
open up my console just to see if we
have any errors and we do not so it
looks like everything installed properly
so over here go ahead and let's make
sure we have this this stuff copied here
and now that we have our firebase config
copied let's go ahead and put it inside
of our app just to get that part knocked
out so we don't have to worry about it
in just a moment so I've got my
directory opened up now and I'll go into
my source folder here and you want to
open your index j s5 so we're going to
want to do a quick require so we're
gonna say Const firebase is equal to
require and then inside of here we want
to put inside of quotes firebase so a
requiring firebase and then underneath
this we want to just go ahead and say
require and then in quotes firebase
slash fire store oops there we go cool
so under this you remember we copied
that stuff from firebase so make sure
you have that copied and let's go ahead
and paste that here now I'm going to
change varta Const
and I'm gonna get rid of these two
comments right here alright and what I
like to do just to make it it might not
actually be cleaner but this is the way
I like to do I like to get rid of this
variable here just get rid of the
variable and then just take the actual
object itself and paste it in between
the parentheses there that's just how I
like to do it but you can do it either
way so now we have firebase initialized
inside of our application I'm saving it
right now and I'm coming over to the
react app just to make sure I don't have
any errors and it says here it looks
like you're using the development build
a firebase jeaious SDK now this is
perfectly fine this is saying we're
using the development build which is
fine because we are in development now
you we're gonna be getting this message
throughout the entire tutorial so we can
safely ignore this particular message so
as you see it here in the console as we
work through the tutorial just ignore
this it's fine alright moving on so the
first thing I like to do is I like to
come in here and delete all this default
stuff that comes with the default react
app so I go into a pas here and inside
of this return I'm actually I'm gonna
get rid of this whole thing and make it
a class so I'll come in here and say
class app extends react component and
now we have a class instead of a
function which the class needs to
actually needs to implement the render
function and inside of the render
function you have to return some HTML so
for now I'll put in a div that just says
hello world cool so I'll save that and
let's see what we end up with really
quick we have hello world here cool so
as most of you probably know the way
that this works is inside of the
index.js file we have this app element
which is represented by this app class
here because we were importing it right
here and what this is doing is react Dom
rendered takes whatever's inside of here
does some react magic to turn it into
actual code that basically we write it
in a react way and then it takes that
react way and turns into actual code
that the browser understands and then it
pushes it into document dot get element
by ID root and if I come in here you can
see if I go to elements do expand this
get rid of this if I go inside a body
here you can see there's this div here
with an ID of root and everything inside
of the react application is going to get
injected inside of this div called root
so you don't actually have to you know I
really want you guys to understand react
so let's go into the public here and
inside the index.html you can see that
that div is actually right here with
root so what I want to do just to kind
of show you and get you really
comfortable with this sort of idea is
instead of call it root I'm gonna call
it
Evernote container so go ahead and call
this Evernote container and I want you
to save it and I want you to take that
copy it and paste it inside of here so
now we're injecting it inside of a div
called Evernote container instead of ruh
and I want you to save both of those
files and come back in here and notice
that it works still and if you come back
over here you can see that that div has
an ID of Evernote container so that's
just to kind of get you a little bit
comfortable with how react is working
and that it's not entirely magic you can
actually come in here and change some of
these things it's not mandatory and you
can actually extend it too this is all
open source you don't have to be afraid
of react alright there's actually one
more thing we need to add so inside of
the source folder create a new file call
that helpers dot J S and inside of here
we're gonna paste some stuff go to the
source code the source code is going to
be linked in the description of this
video go ahead and go to that source
code find at the helpers J's file and
paste this in so what this is going to
be we have a debounce function which is
going to be helpful for us because what
when we are typing inside of the text
editor we're going to want to update the
database live however we don't want to
send
we don't want to send requests every
every single time we type a a letter
we're gonna want to wait for the user to
stop typing for about a second or so
maybe two seconds before we update the
database so that we're not just going
crazy on the database with all these
calls these HTTP calls so we're gonna be
using a deep balance function right here
and then we're also going to have this
export function where you remove HTML
tags that function is going to be for
our preview on the Left sidebar whenever
we see the list of notes we're going to
we're going to remove the HTML for the
preview and basically react quill the
text editor library that we're using
actually stores its it displays it as
actual HTML so we're going to be saving
HTML as a string to the database so when
we display the preview in the sidebar we
don't want to show the HTML tags that
would just look weird so we have this
function here that's going to be
removing the HTML from that so we can
just see the plain text previews so for
the majority of the application we're
going to be using something called width
styles which is actually going to be
from material UI instead of writing
plain CSS but there is going to be a
little of plain CSS for the app level
project so go ahead and open up your app
dot CSS and we want to go ahead and
remove all this stuff this was just the
default CSS that we saw when we first
started up our react application with
react create react app it had the big
you know react logo and it was spinning
around and doing cool stuff we don't
need any of that so go ahead and remove
all that go to the source code and in
the source code you'll find app dot CSS
go ahead copy all of that and paste it
in here we don't want to worry about CSS
in this tutorial so we're going to be
copying all of our Styles from the
source code and pasting that stuff in so
go ahead and save your app dot CSS file
cool so we're ready to go ahead and get
started so let's go ahead and remove
this import logo from the SVG here we're
not gonna be using that that's just the
react logo that's included with the
project
so what we want to do is start with a
constructor and inside of this
constructor we have to go ahead and
implement the super and then what we'll
do is create some initial State so we'll
say this state is equal to and inside of
this object we're going to have three
slices of state one is going to be
called selected note index and that will
be set to null by default these will all
be Nold by default so select it note as
well that'll be null and then notes
which will be the array of all of the
notes that we have and that will also be
null so now that we have our initial
state what we want to do is underneath
the render function we want to go ahead
and implement the react hook called
component didn't mount and what that is
is whenever the this particular
component the app component is loaded
successfully inside of the Dom this will
get called automatically by reacted as a
life cycle hook that is built-in to
react so let's go ahead and implement
component did mount and we want to go
ahead and go into firebase grab all of
the notes and then set our state with
the notes this little slice right here
but in order to do that we actually have
to come up here and import firebase
really quick so underneath all of these
imports let's go ahead and say Const
firebase is equal to require and then
firebase cool so now we have access to
firebase so we want to say firebase and
then that's gonna be dot fire store and
I'm actually going to put these on
individual lines so it's easier for you
guys to see so dot fire store dot
collection and what collection is is
it's basically very similar to a table
in a database our collection we're going
to name notes so we'll go ahead and name
that notes and I'll show you in just a
moment what that looks like in that
little table visualizer on firebase but
for now just follow along so dot
collection notes dot on snapshot now
what on snapshot is this is actually
very interesting this is very powerful
on snapshot is going to automatically
get called whenever this notes collide
is updated inside a firebase so whenever
something gets updated inside of the
notes collection in firebase the
function that we pass into on snapshot
will get called and that specific
function is going to be passed a an
argument automatically that we're going
to be calling server update so that's
going to be the argument for the
function that we're passing into this
and let's go ahead and create a Const
called notes which is going to be our
array so we want to go ahead and set
that equal to server update Docs and
Doc's is a property of the server update
parameter I'm sorry Docs is a property
of the server update object that's
getting passed into our function and we
want to map it and so if you're not
super familiar with the map function in
JavaScript I've got a really good
tutorial on that go ahead and look in
the description and watch that tutorial
it's very short
but it's got a visual representation of
how map works inside of JavaScript and
if you're not very familiar familiar
with that I highly recommend you watch
that tutorial really quick because we're
going to be using it a lot in this
tutorial series so let's go ahead and
say for each dock we want to create a
Const called data and set it equal to
doc data which is a function which grabs
the data from the dock and we want to
add a property to our data object that
we're creating called ID so data ID will
literally just be equal to doc dot ID
and then we're going to return that so
our return data so we successfully have
an array of all of the notes and then we
want to go ahead and update our state so
this set state and inside of here we
want to update the notes slice of our
state with our notes that we just
created right here so we're setting our
notes state equal to this array that we
we just mapped right here so we don't
have anything inside of we don't have
any notes so we can't really see what
this looks like yet but what I want to
do is go ahead and create a console dot
log statement console dot log
notes and I want to save it because I
want to show you guys what this looks
like so as you can see we come here and
when I go to the console we have an
empty array and that's simply because we
don't have any notes inside a firebase
so let's go up here to firebase and I
want you to go back to your database and
you can see this table here so when we
add a collection remember we call that
collection notes okay and we click Next
and then for each note that's going to
be a document and it'll have this auto
ID and the dock the the notes are going
to have two will actually three
properties the first property is going
to be a title and what is call it tests
note from firebase it'll also have a a
body so we'll call it body and then
that's going to actually end up being a
string of HTML so in here I'm just going
to put an h1 tag hello world and at
closing h1 tag and then it'll also have
a timestamp but I'm not going to worry
about the timestamp here in this
particular case because we're going to
automatically generate that timestamp so
I'm gonna click Save and I can see that
we have a note here and if you remember
when I said whenever the notes
collection is updated it's going to
automatically call that on snapshot
function that we're passing a function
into so let's go back over here and as
you can see it went ahead and actually
ran that function automatically simply
because I updated the notes the notes
collection so you can see here now that
we have a title ID and body of a single
note that we just created inside a
firebase so with that being said I'm
gonna go ahead and keep this console dot
log notes here just for reference and
then let's move on so I'm gonna actually
remove all of these tabs up here so I
can keep everything clean and inside of
the source folder I want to create I
actually want to create three other
folders so we'll call the first folder
editor the second folder we will call
sidebar
and then the third folder will call
sidebar item now let's go ahead and get
rid of let's go ahead and knock this
boilerplate stuff out so inside of
editor create a new file called editor
j/s and you're gonna want another file
called Styles j/s and you're gonna want
to do that for each of these so new file
sidebar a s and a styles J s and then
finally sidebar item J s and a Styles j
s for that one as well so let's go
inside of each of these and just create
the classes and the imports that we're
going to need for each of these so that
we can start focusing on the
functionality so start by going into
your editor j s and i want you to find
the editor j s file in the source code
and i want you to copy and paste these
imports here once you have those imports
go ahead and come down here and type in
class editor component that's what we're
going to call this class it's going to
extend react component and inside of
here we'll have a constructor that calls
super and then we have to go ahead and
have the render function and whoops and
the render function has to return some
HTML so what I will do is inside of here
I will just simply say hello from the
editor and that's going to be our class
our boilerplate code for our class and
what we need to do at the very bottom
here is actually export this but we're
going to use with styles so I'm gonna
explain how that works just give me a
second let's go ahead and say export
default with styles which you can see we
are importing right here from material -
UI / core / styles so export default
with styles which takes a argument
because it's a function and that is
going to be styles now we're passing
styles in - with styles with styles is
actually going to return yet another
function so we'll go ahead and
immediately invoke that function that it
returns with our editor
component okay so what styles is is it's
actually going to end up being a
function that we're going to put inside
of the styles J s file here you don't
have to worry about that I'm actually
gonna have you go ahead and copy that
and paste it inside of here from the
source code but I want you to understand
how this is working so inside of here
there's going to be a function that has
a bunch of a bunch of classes that are
going to be they're going to represent
CSS styles here it's taking those styles
and then basically creating an object
called classes or a property and react
it's actually props so it's creating a
prop called classes and we're going to
be able to access those classes from the
it'll look like this it'll be classes
well this dot props top oops this dot
props dot classes dot class name so
that's going to be really helpful for us
shortly so go ahead and save this let's
knock out the boilerplate code for the
other two components so go ahead and go
to your sidebar J's file and inside of
here go ahead go to the source code copy
the imports paste the imports inside of
here and then class side bar sidebar
component extends react component and
again we'll want a constructor here that
calls super and then under here I'll
just copy from my previous file here the
render function and then instead of
Hello from editor we'll say hello from
sidebar and then again we'll say export
default with styles
the first argument will be styles and
the second one will be our sidebar
component okay and let's knock out the
final one so under sidebar item jeaious
go ahead and go into the source code and
copy the imports fourth paste the
imports inside of here and then go to go
ahead and type in class
sidebar item component extends react dot
component and of course it's going to
have a constructor here with super and
then the render function which I will
again copy from the previous one and
instead of sidebar will say sidebar item
so now we have the boilerplate code
actually I need to do the the exports of
export default sidebar item component
nope that's gonna be with styles styles
is the first argument and then the
sidebar item component all right so now
we got all of that done so the second
thing that we want to do is you want to
go into the source code grab the Styles
JS file for each of these three
components and paste them in so I'm
going to go ahead and do that right now
you go ahead and do it as well so I'm
gonna start with my Styles JS file for
my editor so under under editor here
inside of Styles jeaious I simply paste
this and as you can see Styles is a
function with a argument called theme
that's passed into it automatically by
material UI which returns an object of
basically CSS classes and styles so go
ahead and save that and then move on to
the sidebar Styles j/s file go ahead and
copy it from the source code paste that
in and then do the same thing for the
Styles j/s inside of the sidebar item
and once you have all of that we have
all of our boilerplate code so we can
actually go ahead and get started on the
fun stuff so inside of our app dot J's
file I'm actually going to get rid of
all these tabs inside of our app dot J's
file inside of render I want to actually
render out our new components so in
react we can only return one component
but we can have components inside of
other components or we can let me
rephrase that we can only return one
element but we can have other elements
or components inside of that element so
we'll create one parent element
and it'll be a div here and I'll just go
ahead and give this a class name of
let's say app container and then inside
of here let's go ahead and put in our
sidebar component which we are going to
need to import so let's go ahead and
import sidebar component from and that
will be dot board slash sidebar slash
sidebar might as well go ahead and do
the same thing for the editor so import
editor component from dock ford slash
editor forward slash editor okay so we
don't need to import the sidebar item
component because the sidebar component
is going to use the sorry sidebar item
component so we don't have to use that
inside of that j/s so we have that and
let's go ahead and also put our editor
component inside of here cool so let's
save this and see what we end up with
alright cool so a whole bunch of nothing
it's still compiling on my end
let me there we go cool so as you can
see here we have hello from sidebar and
hello from the editor we also have a few
warning messages but we're not gonna
worry about that that's just saying hey
you have imported some stuff but you're
not using it it says no unused bars
that's because we went ahead and knocked
out all those imports before you wrote
the code so just don't worry about these
warnings right now but as you can see
they are importing and displaying the
components as expected alright so what I
want to do now is I want to go ahead and
demonstrate the react quill you know
what it comes with the features of it
and how we're gonna be using it inside
of this application but before we do
that I need you to go to the source code
so go to the description go to the
source code go into the public folder
and then the index.html file and then
what you'll see in the source code at
the top of inside of the header tags at
the very top you'll see a link a link
tag with I'll show you exactly what it
looks like here so you it'll be right
here
and this is what this is is it's the
styles for react quill it's the style
phew so go ahead and paste that in
exactly where you see it here save it
and now we have access to the CSS that
we're going to need for react quilt so
now that we have that I'm gonna go ahead
and move this window over here and
actually bring it a little bit further
over so you can see everything go ahead
and have your editor J s file open and
I'm gonna start moving this HTML onto
its own lines just to make it look clean
and I'm gonna get rid of hello from the
editor okay so the first thing I want to
do here is inside of this render
function at the top I want to go ahead
and D structure out the classes variable
so I will do that now so Const classes
equals this dot props so now I have
access to that classes variable from
this dot props and I'm going to go ahead
and use that here so we're gonna give
this parent div here a class name and
the class name is going to be equal to
classes editor container and now I want
to go ahead and throw in this react
quill element and save and let's see
what we end up with over here so as you
can see we have a text editor inside of
here now
it looks kind of wonky at this at this
moment and that's just due to the styles
because we're gonna have a little extra
room for the sidebar but this sidebar
will be over here and right now we have
hello from the sidebar above is so it
looks a little weird right now but
that's perfectly fine we'll get to that
in just a second but I just wanted to
come in here and kind of show you what a
react quill comes with right off the bat
so as you can see here it comes with all
of what you need in order to get started
with a text editor now it also has some
built-in functions so I'm just going in
here and just kind of showing you that
it has all this stuff built in alright
cool so
it comes with some functions that are
going to be really helpful for us when
trying to use this inside of our
application so now that I've kind of
demonstrated what that looks like I
think it's time to go ahead and start
implementing some of the functions now I
want to go ahead and start implementing
these functions while it does look kind
of weird so we're gonna be using the
console to do a lot of logging here so
just go ahead and have your console open
and let's go ahead and get started
implementing these functions all right
so the first property we're going to
utilize from react quill is value so the
value we will set equal to this state
dot txt and you know we've got this
state variable here so what we're gonna
do is whatever the state whatever the
text state is it's going to be the value
property of react quill so as we update
this state it's going to update the
react quill value property the second
thing that we're gonna throw in here is
on change and we're gonna have a
function called this update body so I'm
gonna put this stuff on its own line
really quick just make it look clean so
we have value and on change now this to
update body is going to be a function
that is going to be asynchronous that's
going to set some state and once the
state updates we're going to call an
update function that is going to do some
stuff I don't want to talk too far ahead
so let's go ahead and implement update
body so I'm gonna put up day body
directly under my return sorry under my
render so I'll go to my render function
and create a variable called update body
which I'll set to a function now this is
going to be an asynchronous function so
go ahead and add your async keyword and
it's going to accept a value and we're
gonna do stuff with that value so like I
said we're going to set some state but
we're gonna wait for that state to
update so we're gonna say oh wait this
outset state
and the chunk of state that we want to
update is going to be text and we're
gonna update it with Val and once that
state is updated we're gonna call this
update which we do not have yet so
underneath update body we will create a
function called update now this is where
things get a little somewhat complicated
so I'm gonna do my best to explain it
for you so we have a function called
update and we're gonna set it equal to D
bounce and we're gonna pass a function
into D bounce which is going to be the
actual function so I'll explain this in
just a second I just want to get this
out of the way okay
so D bounces and our helpers so if I go
to helpers J s we imported we imported
that right here so D bounces in our
helpers here and what we don't want to
do is every single time the value
changes go to the data base on firebase
and update it because what that means is
as the users typing in their text every
single time they type a letter or
character or a backspace or anything at
all it's going to make an HTTP request
to the database and that's going to get
a little crazy so what we want to do is
we want to wait for the user to stop
typing for one-and-a-half seconds before
we call the database and what this
allows us to do is be a lot more
efficient with with our resources so
this is called debouncing and we are
basically this helpers let's go back to
it so I can show you this helpers
function debounce
is going to take a function okay so
that's why we're passing our update
function to our debounce function and
what's gonna happen is whenever we're
typing each time it tries to call update
again it's gonna basically in essence
cancel the last one until the user stops
typing for at least 1.5 seconds and when
they stop typing for 1.5 seconds the
function will actually go all
and update will complete so hopefully
that makes sense so the second parameter
that we want to pass to this to bounce
is the amount of time and like I said
1.5 seconds which is going to be fifteen
hundred milliseconds so what is it we
want to actually do with our update
function well for now I just want to so
will say come back later for now all I
want to do is log lock some stuff so I
can demonstrate the debouncing effect so
we'll just come in here and say it
console dot log updating database and
let's see if this works the first time
through alright so I'm coming in here
into my text editor and I'm just typing
some stuff I'm typing some stuff typing
typing typing and now I'm going to stop
typing okay you saw that I stopped
typing for one-and-a-half seconds and
then this function appeared it did not
appear 20 times since I typed you know
20 times or whatever it only appeared
once and it waited for me to stop typing
so that's that is something that I
wanted to teach you guys as debouncing
and it's very important for this
tutorial especially because we're
updating a database through the use of a
user typing so that can you know if we
have hundreds and hundreds or thousands
and thousands of users and we're
updating the database every single time
a user types of key that's gonna get out
of hand so we're gonna use debouncing in
this tutorial okay so now what I want to
do is start making this look a little
better so I demonstrated you know what
react quill does and you know a little
bit about debouncing so what I want to
do now is I want to start focusing on
getting the sidebar component set up and
we already went through getting items
from the database on you know as soon as
we load the app we get all of the notes
from the database so since we already
have access to the notes we might as
well go ahead and start working on our
sidebar to display those notes so go
ahead and go to your sidebar component
sidebar j/s and let's go ahead and get
started work
this now the first thing that we want to
do is go ahead and go under our super
inside of the constructor and say this
state is equal to and we want to put an
adding note and we'll set that equal to
false and we will put a title which we
will set to null by default cool so
let's go ahead and destructor a couple
of property variables so inside of here
go ahead and prepare this inside of
these curly braces the variables that we
wanted to structure out are gonna be
notes
classes and selected note index now
we're not passing these props yet so
since we're not passing these properties
yet it's we're probably gonna get an
error if not then that's great but we'll
go and we'll actually pass nulls right
now so let's go to the let's go to the
app KS and let's look we have notes
classes is automatically passed in
through with styles and we have selected
note index so let's go ahead and pass
those two in now we have selected note
index so we can just go ahead and go
here inside of our sidebar component
element we can say selected note index
is equal to this state dot selected note
index I'm gonna put this on its own line
and then the other one was notes which
we also have so notes is equal to this
dot state dot notes and so now we won't
get an error so now that we have these
destructured inside of our sidebar j/s
file I want to go ahead and remove hello
from the sidebar and I want to give our
our parent div here a class name so we
have a class name and we use the classes
object classes sidebar
container alright so inside of here I
want to go ahead and add a button and
it's gonna be a button with a capital B
and that's because it is a if we go up
here I can show you a it is a component
from the material UI core and we're
going to use that because it's going to
just make it look a little better by
default so we're gonna add a few things
here we're gonna have it on click and
the on click function that we're going
to provide here we're going to write
that function so for now we'll just call
a new note BTN click and that's a
function we're going to write in just a
moment so keep that in mind we'll get
right back to that I'm go ahead and add
a class name and that class name will be
classes dot new note BTN and inside of
here I'm just gonna put the text to say
new note we'll change this in just a
second so let me go ahead and let's add
this new note button click function
underneath the render function so here
we will say new note BTN click is equal
to a function and for now I'm just gonna
have it say console dot log and I'm
gonna say new BTN clicked cool so let's
see what we ended up with so when we
come back over here you can see that we
have this sidebar here and that's
because we already have the styles for
it we just added the container class
here which are all inside of the Styles
JS file so we we have the sidebar
container and we have this new notes
button here I'm going to clear this and
I'm going to click it you can see now it
says new BTN clicked so we know the
button is working so below the button
still inside of the div container but
below the button we're gonna put two
curly braces and what we want to do is
we want to have the ability to add a new
note and if we click on new note button
we want the new note input to show up so
let's go ahead and say if this
State DOT adding note put a question
mark after we're gonna use our ternary
operator as you can see we have this
adding note slice of state which is
false by default so by default this is
not going to show up so that's good
because we don't want the user to
suddenly see add a new note unless they
go and explicitly click that button so
if this does state that adding note
we're gonna do some stuff we're gonna
return a div you know let me go ahead
and get that otherwise we're gonna just
go ahead and return null okay so let's
go ahead go inside of this div and put
in the stuff that we actually want to
return if this not adding state this
does state that adding note is true so
the div is gonna have an input an input
and the type of the input type is equal
to text and a class name is going to be
equal to classes dot new note input and
we're gonna have an on key up function
but first let's add a placeholder
placeholder and the placeholder is just
the text that's going to be inside of
the input before the user starts to
enter text inside of it manually so
we'll just say enter note title and
again we will have a non key up function
on key up and so whenever the user
starts typing in there whenever they
lift their finger off of a key a
function will get fired and it gets
passed the event by default and we want
to pass that event to our own function
which we will call this stuff update
title and we will pass an e dot target
value which is going to be the target
element of the event that got fired off
that we're passing in from here and the
value of that so we're going to pass
that to our update title function which
for now come down here update title is
equal to a function that takes some text
so just put text txt and for now just
console.log
and I'm going to say here it is and I'm
going to display the text that we passed
update title okay so let's see here go
ahead and I think it's safe to save this
let's find out
clear this see what happens when I click
this we got new BTN clicked but it looks
like oh yeah that's right we have to
actually flip that variable so when we
have new BTN clicked we need to go ahead
new note BTN clicked we need to go ahead
and flip that variable in the state the
specifically the this state adding note
because otherwise if we don't flip that
to true this will never display right
here so we need to go ahead and do that
alright this set state and then inside
of here we want to go ahead and update
adding note and what we want to set it
to is not the state dot adding note so
if that's false it'll flip it to true if
it's true it'll flip it to false it's
just saying whatever this state to
adding note is we just want it to be the
opposite and we also want to reset the
title and the reason why we want to
reset the title is because when we're
adding a new note if we start typing in
a title and then we want to stop adding
a note when we go to add another note we
don't want that previous title to still
be in the input so we're just gonna
reset the title and save let's see if
that works for us ok let's come over to
new note and when I click it you can see
now I have this input here and when I
start to type inside of it it's saying
it is actually logging it here as we
expected and then when I click new note
it makes it go away because we're
flipping that variable when I click it
again you can see it's empty that's
because we're resetting that title
that's exactly what we wanted to do but
here's the problem when I click new note
it still says a new note I want it to
say cancel so I wanted to say new note
here because it makes sense I want to
click that I want to create a new note
but now I don't want it to say new note
any more I wanted to say cancel so what
we want to do is we want to go inside
where we put the text for that button
where it says new note hee
let's put some JavaScript in there so
two curly braces and we want to do a
ternary operator and we'll say this
state that adding note so if that's true
we want to go ahead and say cancel
otherwise we want to go ahead and say
new note so let's save that and it says
new note and when I click it now it says
cancel okay that's that's exactly what
we want it to do cool so let's go ahead
and move on all right so now what we
want to do is we have that input we have
the enter note title input let's go
ahead and go directly underneath that
and let's create another button with a
capital v and we want to create our
submit button so let's give it a class
name is that equal to classes dot new
note submit BTN all right I'm gonna put
that on its own line make sure you guys
can see everything and then I want to
add an on click function and we're gonna
call this dot new note whenever we click
this button and we have to create this
function but for now we'll go ahead and
put some text in here that says submit
note cool so let's create a function
called new note and for now just console
dot log let's just log the entire state
okay so we'll save this we'll come back
over here
clear this console so it's clean new
note now you can see the submit note
button is here I'll start typing in a
title and when I click Submit now the
state is adding note is true and the
title is null the reason why the title
is null is because inside of update
title we are logging instead of setting
the state so let's go ahead and set the
state
alright so the title the idol we will
simply set that to text and then we will
save
okay so let's demo this one more time
say this oops this is a title and I'm
gonna click Submit note and you can see
now that the state is properly updated
cool so there we go cool so I want to
come in here and I want to go ahead and
start working on the list of all of the
notes on the side so let's go ahead and
do that so what where we want to be is
outside of these curly braces right here
we want to go beyond that and we want to
add a list element with a capital L and
then inside of the list element we want
to put two curly braces because what
we're gonna do is we're going to map all
of the notes that we get from the props
so all of these notes here that we're
passing in from the apt is we want to
take all of those notes and map those to
actual elements so again if you don't if
you're not super comfortable with the
map function in JavaScript I do have a
tutorial for it that I think will really
help you guys understand the map
function in detail go ahead and look in
the description for that video and then
come back to this if you are familiar
with in the map function and let's go
ahead and move on so we're gonna say
notes dot map and we will have two
parameters here we will have note so for
each note and its index we're gonna go
ahead and return some HTML so I'm gonna
get rid of this curly brace
I mean semicolon get rid of these
semicolons here so I'm gonna have a div
and in react whenever we map or whenever
we're iterating through and creating a
bunch of elements we need to give a key
to the parent and I'm just going to use
our index as the key
and what we want to do is for each and
every single note we want to create a
sidebar sidebar item component and site
of our item component is going to take
several properties so let's go ahead and
start working on those props so the
first one is going to be note and that's
going to be equal to the note we're on
the second one is going to be index and
that's going to be equal to the index
we're on and I put a comma here which I
shouldn't have all right the then we're
gonna have selected note index which is
going to equal selected note index which
we're getting right here so we have
direct access to that then we're gonna
say select note which is gonna be a
function property here
and we're just gonna say this does
select note which I believe we do not
have implemented yet so let's go ahead
and create select note it's just gonna
be a function that for now I'm just
gonna say console dot log select note
just to get that out of the way really
quick and we'll come back to it then
we're also gonna have a delete note
function which will do the exact same
thing that we just did here this dot
delete note and we'll go and I'm just
gonna copy this function and paste it
and then replace with delete okay
cool so now we have a sidebar item
inside of a div but underneath the
sidebar item we want to go ahead and put
a divider and all the divider is is it's
just gonna be a small dividing line
between each of these sidebar item
components so that you can distinguish
you can distinguish them basically so
I'm gonna save and let's just take a
look and see what we've got so far we've
got an error so it says cannot read
property map of null and the reason why
we are getting this is because let's see
it's go back up here we're mapping
through notes and map is a function of
arrey object okay so if notes is null
then we're calling map on something that
does not have a function called map and
for now an editor notes
sorry not an editor in apt is notes as
null we as soon as we load the sidebar
component we're passing in a null now
later on you can see that notes is being
updated but this is asynchronous meaning
that this isn't being so notes isn't
being set until after we're calling map
inside of the sidebar component and
that's that's one of the frustrations
that a lot of people have to deal with
in JavaScript is the asynchronous aspect
of it so let's go ahead and take care of
this problem right now so in order to
fix this little hiccup that we
inevitably will have run into I don't
want to go ahead and take this entire
return statement and I want to cut some
I cut it so that I can paste it and I'm
gonna put an if statement here where I
say if notes so in other words if notes
is not null then I want to paste that
return statement into there else if it
is null I want to go ahead and return a
small div that's just gonna say add a
note exclamation point which you know
this you'll probably never even see
because even if the array itself is
empty it's still gonna go down this
route so in reality we could just put an
empty div here so I'm just gonna
actually just gonna actually put an
empty div here instead and so what we're
doing is we're saying if notes is not
null then let's go ahead and do all this
stuff and if notes is null we're just
going to return an empty div and so
what's gonna happen is inside of the
Apps jet app.js file when it first
renders the sidebar component notes is
gonna be null because notes is null
inside of the state by default then when
this component didn't mount goes through
and successfully retrieves all of the
notes
and sets the state know it's equal to
notes this is gonna rerender with notes
not being null and then it's gonna come
back into this render statement notes
will then not be null anymore and it
will go ahead and call all of this and
so map can actually be called on an
empty array that's perfectly fine it
just means we're not gonna have any
sidebar item components that's the
behavior we want if notes is null again
map simply doesn't exist on norm so
that's why we went ahead and create this
else I hope that makes good sense for
you guys so come back over here and
refresh you see hello from the sidebar
item and that's because we have one note
inside of firebase so it's rendering out
one sidebar item component and if we go
to our sidebar item component you can
see that all we're doing here is saying
hello from the sidebar item so what we
really need to do is go in and start
working on our sidebar item component
now okay so let's go ahead go to our
sidebar item J's file go ahead and let's
remove the constructor here because
we're actually not going to be using any
State inside of this sidebar item
component only props so since we're only
gonna be using props we can pretty much
call this a stateless component although
it's not by definition because it is
going to be using the props so in a
sense it's kind of a functional
component so we'll go ahead and just
call it a functional component so this
is gonna be a functional component so
the first thing that we want to do is
inside of our render I'm going to get
rid of this hello from the side of our
item and put everything on woops put
everything inside on its own line and
indent it then at the top of the render
function I'm going to go ahead and D
structure out some stuff from this table
props so if you remember we had a bunch
of different props that we were passing
in from the sidebar component we had a
note index selected note index select
note and delete know so let's go ahead
and grab all of those so index note
classes which is being passed in through
with styles by default and selected note
index cool so the delete note and select
note we're not going to actually utilize
inside of the render function we're
going to utilize that elsewhere so we
don't need to destructure that here cool
so let's return and let's go ahead and
say the key here let's just add a key
here and we'll set that equal to index
then let's put a list item in here and
so what we're gonna say is for each
sidebar item component that we have it's
going to be a a list item which is a
material UI component so if we look back
in here we have this list component
which is also a material UI component
and we're looping through in creating
list items so let's give a class name
whoops got to go inside of the tag here
let's give a class name and we're gonna
set it equal to classes dot list item
book list item and then let's give it a
selected which I'll explain that in just
a second
selected note index is equal to index
okay so let's go ahead and explain this
so selected is a property of the list
item component which if this selected
variable is true then it's going to be
highlighted and that's basically it and
so what we're gonna say is we want it to
be considered selected if selected note
index is equal to our current index and
this index is actually our loop index
that we have right here so if the
current selected note index is equal to
the current item Ron then we can safely
say that this is the one that is
selected okay so let's go ahead and add
aligned items and let's set that equal
to flex start we can just use a normal
string here celebrate
alright so let's add a div okay so
inside of this list item will have a div
and inside of this div actually let's
add some class name is that a class name
here class is dot and we'll call this
text section and let's add an on click
on click let me just try to get
everything on it on its own line so you
can see everything clearly on click and
we're gonna pass a function so we're
gonna say this dot select note select
note and it'll take the note and the
index okay so we have this class name
and on click afford the div here and
let's go ahead and inside of this div
use a list item text component and again
this is just this is just from material
UI right here is these are just
components that come from material UI
that just make making things look good
really easy so all of these things tend
to just use properties so we're gonna go
ahead and add them our primary is going
to be our note dot title and our
secondary so it's going to have primary
and secondary text our secondary text
now this is where we get to use another
one of our help for helper functions so
for now I'm not gonna use it
and I'll show you why we need it in just
a second so note body note body dot sub
string sub string 0 30 plus dot dot dot
okay so I'm gonna go ahead and explain
what I'm doing here so note dot body
could be a massive string because it's
the entire body of the note it's all of
the text inside of the note so we don't
want to display that on the sidebar it's
just too much text so I'm taking the
first 30 characters of that and then if
it's more than 30 characters I'm also
adding dot dot dot at the end of that so
let's go ahead and
let's see what happens if I save now
let's see if we can see perfect okay
so test note from firebases the title
and the secondary text or so the test
note from firebase is our primary you
can see primary is no title and our
secondary is this substring here as you
can see it's working as expected but as
you can see this is HTML and the reason
why it's HTML again is because in
firebase we are storing this as HTML
react quill actually stores the value of
whatever you're typing inside of here as
HTML so we have that helper j/s file and
the second function here is called
remove HTML tags and that is exactly
what we're going to use here to get rid
of that that HTML so let's go ahead and
take this section here and cut and then
we're gonna say remove HTML tags and
pass that as the parameter save it come
back over here and now you can see it
just says hello world dot instead of at
HTML cool so what we want to do is under
our list item text we have the closing
div tag cool so underneath the closing
div tag we want to create a delete icon
that's the capital D delete icon and we
want to add an on click function
obviously and the on click function is
going to be this dot delete note and
we'll give it a class name as well
so the class name is going me classes
dot delete icon
make sure you don't make sure it's
spelled exactly like this because if it
has a capital D as you're creating these
class names just if you are wondering if
you're spelling it correctly you can
look at the video of course but you can
also go to your Styles j/s file and just
look and see exactly how it's spelled
here so you can see which classes you
have available and all of that inside of
your Styles dot J's file for each
component so I'm gonna save that come
back over here and now you can see there
is a delete icon which for now if I
click it it's gonna break us because we
have not implemented this delete note so
we have two functions that we need to
implement we have to implement our
delete note and select note functions so
underneath our render function let's go
ahead and create a select note function
which will take an N and an eye which is
note and index and you can see we are
already passing note in index to our
select note function so N and I and
we're just gonna say this dot props dot
select no and we're gonna pass and and I
to that and so this dot props that
select note if we go back we can see
that we are in fact sending a property
over called select note which is equal
to this da select note which is a
function inside of the sidebar component
which is just logging select note ok
keep that in mind so I will actually
save this and let's demonstrate that so
if I click this note you can see now it
says select note and that is in fact
coming from the sidebar component so
it's KITT it's calling that parent
function now we need to add delete note
delete no which is gonna take note
whoops
spell that nope and you can see when we
call delete note here this dot delete no
we are passing the current note in so
what we want to do is we don't want to
just let the lead the the user
accidentally delete notes so if they
accidentally click the trash can icon
and it deletes their entire you
no poem that they've been writing for a
month they'd be pretty mad so what we
want to do is say if window dot confirm
and I'm gonna put two back ticks here
and I've made a lot of tutorials in the
past and people do get pretty confused
about this so I want to take a second to
really explain this
the backticks tend to be underneath the
escape button and above the tab button
on a standard keyboard
they are backticks they are not
apostrophes they are not quotation marks
they're backticks and what the back
ticks allow you to do is they allow you
to write in a string but also allow you
to add JavaScript to that string and
then it renders it out afterwards so
please make sure if you if this part is
confusing to you just make sure you're
using the back ticks before posting a
comment so let's say are you sure you
want to delete : and then this is where
we add our JavaScript and then in order
to do that we just put a dollar sign and
opening the open and closing curly brace
and we'll say note that title and see it
just takes this JavaScript and adds it
to this string essentially so if that's
true this dot props dot delete note note
and I'll save and I'll show you what
this does so I'm gonna click delete note
it says are you sure you want to delete
test note from firebase I click yeah I
do want to delete that and now you can
see it log is delete know since in the
side bar component we're just logging
delete note all right so we got through
the side bar item component so we are
getting pretty close here we're actually
getting to almost a functional Evernote
clone so if we go back to our sidebar
component we what we don't want to do is
we don't want to just log stuff we want
to actually select notes and delete
notes so if we go to our app.js file in
the sidebar component you can see we
have a select selected note index and we
have notes as props but what we really
also need is we also need a
of functions that we need to pass as
props from the app J's file and those
functions are going to be delete note
new note and select note so let's go
ahead and create those functions inside
of the app dot J's file go ahead and
create those functions we'll add the
functionality for those functions inside
of the app dot J's file and then we'll
go back into the sidebar component and
remove these console dot log statements
and actually implement the app j/s
functions okay let's go ahead and do
that okay so let's go to our app.js file
and you can see our sidebar component
here let's go ahead and start adding in
the props so delete note we'll save this
dot delete note which doesn't exist yet
select no nope not selected no we want
to have make sure it's called select
note because it's a function and we will
go ahead and give it this select note
which does not exist yet and then
finally we will have new note new note
which we will again set to this dot new
note which does not exist yet cool so
let's make them all exist now so let's
see what do we want to start with I hmm
I think select note let's do select note
first and the reason why I want to do
select note first is because that way we
can select the note we can show that the
selected property for the sidebar items
list items is working correctly and also
demonstrate the text will have to go
into the editor component in order to do
a few small things so that when we
select this that text actually appears
over here so I want to go ahead and
knock that out so that we can focus on
the other stuff so let's go ahead and go
to our select note let's create that
select note and we will expect select
note to take a note and an index whoa
and let's just say this set state
and we'll update some state here and
we'll update the selected note index
which we have the index so index and
then select a note selected note and we
will set that equal to note so I think
we already have select note implemented
inside of the sidebar item so let's go
to the sidebar item and just verify that
select note we are calling that and then
inside of the sidebar select note is
just logging so what we want to do is
actually call this stop props this stop
props select note and we want to pass in
the note and the index now let's just
make sure that order is correct it is
note and index so it's in that order
note and index and we need to actually
for select note we actually need to
accept n and I and inside of the sidebar
item component you can see we are in
fact passing the note and the index
that's what N and I stand for we are
passing that so we just need to make
sure that we accept those as arguments
here in this function inside the sidebar
and once we save in theory this should
this should work now away says note is
not defined that's in the sidebar line
74 do yes because it's N and I not note
an index so save that that air should go
away correct so what happens when I
click this when I click that now you can
see it's highlighted so we know that it
is actually updating the state correctly
because now we know that this is
selected so it's it's working what's not
working yet is we're not displaying that
information over here so let's go ahead
and go into our editor component and
start we need to do a few things to
actually display the currently selected
note so let's see let's start with the
app.js file because we're gonna have to
pass in some properties to our editor
component I know this is all over the
place guys so just bear with me there's
a lot going on in this tutorial it is
kind of an intermediate level tutorial
and there's a lot that needs to be
covered so that's why I'm kind of moving
quickly and sporadically but this is the
kind of
this is the way I actually work when I
write code is I I'm always going over
the place I'm not focused on one
particular thing I'm focused on the task
that I'm trying to complete which could
be in six different files so it kind of
can seem like I'm all over the place but
in reality I'm just focused on one task
at a time here so what we want to pass
to the editor component is a selected
note which not select no selected note
and we want to make sure that we set
that equal to the state selected note
and then we want to pass a selected note
index which will be this state dot
selected note index and then finally we
want to pass notes which is this state
dot notes now if we don't have a
selected note if we have not selected a
note at all then we don't want to render
this editor component whatsoever so
let's cut that and then let's put some
curly braces and say this state dot
selected note question mark so a ternary
operator go ahead and render that out :
in other words else we're just going to
return null cool so I will save that and
let's see what happens when I click this
so I click it and now this appears so we
know again that our this dot state
selected note piece of state is updating
correctly so I just want to demonstrate
that one more time we do not have the
editor here I click this now the editor
is there cool so now we just need to go
into our editor component and actually
accept those properties and begin
displaying them okay so where we want to
start is you can see we have value and
value is the value of the react quill so
it's whatever is inside of here and it's
HTML it's one big string of HTML that's
what value is so it uses that value to
render out all this stuff now right now
this state text is always an empty
string so
what we have to do is we have to go in
and take we have to update the this date
text state with whatever property we
have passed in so let's go ahead and
implement some lifecycle hooks to do
that but we're gonna have to implement
two lifecycle hooks and I will explain
that in just a second so let's just go
ahead and implement it and then I'll
explain why we're doing it this way so
component did mount okay I explained
lifecycle hooks a little earlier so
we'll say this set state and we're gonna
go ahead and set all the state we're
gonna say this text is going to simply
be this dot state dot I'm sorry this dot
props this top props that selected note
body then we also have a title which is
going to be this dot props dot selected
note dot title and then finally our ID
slice of state is going to be this top
props dot selected note ID cool so when
we mount the component when we first
mount it it's gonna set this state so
I'm going to save it and I want to see
what happens when we mount it I click it
now you can see hello world is being
rendered as an h1 tag or a heading one
here it's being read or rendered
properly that's great but see what's
gonna happen is if we have multiple
notes here how much you think about this
for a second okay
I'll prove it in just a second but I
want you to think about it first so
let's say we have two notes and I select
this note
well component didn't mount is called
when it first gets when that component
first gets pushed into the Dom so when
we click this it renders this this react
quill component and component did mount
is called now if we come over here and
select a different note this component
is already mounted component didn't
Mountain is not going to get called
again so how can we possibly re-up
date our state with the new props well
what we're gonna have to do is we're
gonna have to use another lifecycle hook
called this top
I mean component did update and use an
if statement inside of it to tell
whether or not it is time to update the
state or not so I want to go ahead and
just take a second and prove this and so
that it's not just theory so let's go
ahead and do that now all right so I'm
over at my firebase console and I've got
the database table here so I'm gonna add
a new note so I'm gonna add a document
Auto ID and then we'll have a title and
you know I'll just be like yo yo what's
up and then I'll put a body here and
I'll just put nothing much and then give
it an ID which I actually I don't think
the ID is supposed to be in here so I'll
just give it a title in a body and then
save it and that was supposed to be HTML
let me actually update that really quick
the the body is supposed to be HTML me
we'll just give it a h h2 let's give it
a ch2 give us some variants here okay so
I'm adding this note really quick so
when I come back over here you can see I
have a second note because it updates
automatically so what do you thinks
gonna happen when I click this just as I
explained right I'm gonna click this
it's not calling component did mount
again you can see that this is now the
selected note because it's highlighted
so it's updating state properly the
problem is it's not updating the react
kwill component at all and that's
because we're calling component didn't
mount instead of component did update
but we have to do both okay
so we have to do both so I just wanted
to prove that really quick show you that
the problem exists and why we're doing
it this way so component did update okay
so this react suck gets called whenever
the component properties are updated and
so we are gonna put an if statement in
here that says if this dot props dot
selected note dot ID does not equal this
state dot ID so that means if I come
over here and I click this one so say
this is selected and then I come over
here and try to select it again is
not gonna call this function okay
instead it's saying if the ID of the one
that you've just selected is different
from the one that it's displaying then
we want to go ahead and call this again
which is set States so I'm going to copy
this and add some curly braces here and
paste this in save it so now I'll select
this note you can see it says hello
world and then I'll come over here and
select this note and you can see that it
does in fact display the note as
expected so now I can go back and forth
between these two notes so this is great
the only other thing we need to do
inside of the editor component is
implement our update function so instead
of logging let's call this dot props dot
note update this dot props that note
update is that what we called it let me
go back to the app dot J's file
doo-doo-doo looks like we forgot to add
that so I'm going to inside of the
app.js file inside of the editor
component opening tag we need to add one
more prop and we're going to call it
note update note update and we will set
that equal to this dot note update which
does not exist so I'll come down here
and just quickly say note update is a
function and I want to say note update
let's see
node update takes an ID and a note
object okay and I just want to log those
whenever this happens for now okay so
back to the editor so now that we have
this we can say this dot props that note
update and remember it takes an ID and a
note object so the ID is clearly going
to be this state ID easy enough but this
note object is going to be it's going to
have two things it's gonna have a title
which will simply be the state title and
it's also going to have a body which is
going to be
this does States dot body okay we save
that and so if I come over here and I
start trying to update the note so I'd
just be like yo I'm just typing some
stuff in here and I stopped typing for
1.5 seconds you can see that it does
console.log the ID and the note object
and body is undefined here so let's see
why is body undefined so this state dot
body appears to be undefined let's see
ah so it should be text instead of body
so this state dot text caught myself on
that just in time so let's go back over
here and try to update this so a type
type type type and then I let go and you
can see that body is what we would hope
it would be so perfect now of course
it's not actually updating that in the
database yet and that's because inside
of the app dot JS file we are simply
logging and we're not going to firebase
but like I said I wanted to just knock
out this editor stuff so we could get
back to our app to app dot J's functions
and we can start finishing up the app's
functionality so with that being said
let's go ahead and head over to our app
dot J's file and start knocking out all
those functions that we added to the
sidebar component and also this note
update function here okay so what do we
want to start with let's actually start
with our note update function since we
already pretty much have it ready so
what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and update firebase so we're gonna
say firebase dot firestore dot
collection and the name of our
collection was notes dot doc and we have
the ID already because we're passing it
in right here so we have the ID for the
document very convenient and we're gonna
say update and all we have to do for
update is pass in the object and it's
gonna be title so if you remember if we
go to firebase which I'm not gonna do
but you can imagine you can look at it
yourself if you want as well the object
the
object inside of the document is gonna
have a title in a body but we also want
to add a timestamp to it and that's so
that if you guys want to extend this
application anyway you can actually
utilize that timestamp to show when it
was last updated so we'll say the title
is equal to note ABS dot title the body
okay the body is equal to note Hogs dot
body and then the timestamp is going to
be equal to firebase that firestore dot
field value dot server timestamp and
this what this is gonna do is it's a
firebase function that's going to
generate a timestamp for us on the
server so we don't have to worry about
trying to create a date/time object and
all of that it's going to handle it for
us okay
cool so I'm gonna save this and let's
test this out let's go over to yo what's
up and instead of nothing much I want to
come over here and say hello and now you
can see over here it actually did in
fact update firebase because the body
has been updated to hello inside of the
preview as well so let's go to firebase
and just make sure that that updated
inside of the table so I went to my
firebase console I'm going to database
and then I'm going to go to that note
and you can see now it says hello
instead of nothing much perfect cool so
now that we have that working we have no
update working let's go ahead and add
the ability to create a new note okay so
let's go underneath note update and
create a function called new note now
new note is going to be asynchronous and
it's going to accept a title
asynchronous and is going to accept a
title so by default the new notes body
will be empty and it'll just have a
title so we're gonna say Const note is
equal to an object and inside of this
object we will have a title
which will be equal to title which is
coming from right here and we will also
have a body which we will manually empty
string that now below the note we're
gonna say Const note
I'm sorry new from D B is equal to oh
wait so we're gonna await a firebase
call dot firestore dot collection the
collection is notes goodness dot ad so
we're adding we're using the add
function which allows us to add an item
to the collection and it's gonna have a
title which is going to be note dot
title it's going to have a body which is
going to be equal to
note note body which is just that empty
string and then time stamp which we can
just we can actually just go over here
and copy what we had here so we're gonna
create it with a time stamp here ok so
now that's the new note from DB so what
we're doing is we're just setting we're
creating this in firebase and then we're
waiting for that to respond from the
server and then whatever the response is
from the server we're setting that equal
to a variable called new from DB so
below that we want to go ahead and
create a Const called new ID and set
that equal to new from DB da ID so that
we can have access to that that document
ID that's automatically generated by
firebase we can have access to that
because we're gonna need access to that
we're using that throughout the
application as you've noticed so you
know right here for instance we're using
it right here you can see it all
throughout the application right here as
well so we need access to that so what
we're doing is we're just grabbing that
from the response that's why we're
accessing that then we're gonna await
again we're gonna await this dot set
state because set state is actually
asynchronous inside of react and we're
gonna update some state here we're
guessing notes we want to update the
notes array and we want to use the
spread operator to say it should be all
of the notes we already have so this dot
state done notes
along with the new note which note is
this object right here okay and let's
see looks like yeah okay sorry about
that
so we're awaiting that and then we want
to say Const new note index so we want
to go ahead and find the index of the
new note inside of that notes variable
so I'm gonna say this state dot notes
dot index of whoa
index of and I'm gonna use so index of
is a function of the array object that
finds the index of a particular item
inside of an array and so what we have
to pass it is the actual item inside of
the array now I'm gonna go ahead and do
it this way this state dot notes dot
filter okay so I'm going to filter
through that array and I'm gonna find
the one where the note is equal to the
current note the note that we're on so
we're iterating through for each note we
want the one where note that ID is equal
to nu ID now that's going to return an
array because filter returns an array
but we know for a fact it's only going
to return one item because of this right
here so since it's only gonna return one
item we can just go ahead and safely
return the zero index and know that that
will be the one that we were looking for
okay so let's let's look at this line
really quick Const new note index this
dot state notes the index of so we're
finding the index of this one and this
one is this state notes dot filter so
we're going through each and we're
iterating through the the notes and
we're looking for the one where it's
equal to the ID right here so we find
the one with this ID inside of notes and
then we are selecting that automatically
okay hope that makes sense
this set state we're gonna set the state
now and we're gonna say selected note is
equal to this state dot notes and we're
gonna use that index that we just got
that new note index gosh
new note index BS code is not loving me
today selected note index will simply be
equal to new note index okay so why is
it we did all this well when we create a
new note we want to go to the firebase
add the new note in to firebase and then
we want to update the currently selected
note with the one we just created now
let's demonstrate that to see why that's
a good thing hopefully this works so I'm
gonna create a new note I'm gonna say
test note I'm just gonna call it test
note and I'm gonna click submit note
here and you can see that it did not
successfully add the note so inside of
sidebar j/s 72
it's logging something instead of
calling a function so let's go ahead and
let's fix that so inside of sidebar
component on line 72 correct we are
actually logging instead of calling the
parent function so let's see the new
note takes the title so all we have to
do is say here we just have to say this
stuff props dot new note and pass it
this dot props dot title this dot state
title actually this does state title so
we want to pass in this state title to
our app dot J's new note function and
then once that happens we want to set
some state really quick just to reset
everything that we're gonna say title is
null and adding note is going to be
false cool so let's see what happens now
when I come over here and try to add a
new note call it test note submit the
note and it creates test note and
firebase
and then it automatically selects it for
us and it automatically selects it here
too so I'm just gonna say is this
working
question mark wait for it to update and
you can see it does in fact update it
over here fantastic so this is actually
coming along pretty well so let's move
on I think the next thing that we're
gonna want to do is be able to delete
notes so what I will do is come over to
the app.js file and let's implement our
delete note function so under new note
create a function called delete no
delete note is going to take the note
object itself and we are going to say
Const note index note index is equal to
this state dot notes dot index of note
cool so now we have the note index and
we're gonna say if this does were typing
at an awkward angle
okay this state dot selected note index
if this dot state does selected note
index is equal to note index then we'll
say this set state whoops
stop set state selected notes index and
we'll set that to null and I'll explain
why we're doing this in just a second
and selected note we will also set to
null and then we'll have an else
statement here where we will actually do
the stuff and then we'll say this dot
state dot notes dot length if it's a
length if that's greater than one then
we're gonna do this and this is this dot
select note select note we'll call
select no if
this select note which we have
implemented here so it takes a note
tenant index so this select note will go
ahead and call that with the note and
the index now this is where things are
gonna get a little weird so just try to
follow with me and I'll explain it as I
go okay the note is going to be this
state dot notes and then we're gonna
access it by a index which is gonna be
this state dot selected note index minus
one and the reason why it's minus one is
because now there's one less so when we
delete a note we don't like if we're
already if it's selected for instance if
if we have the note selected then what
we're doing is we're d selecting the
note that's why we have this F statement
here so if we have this note selected
right here already and then I delete the
note that's already selected we want to
deselect that note in state because we
don't want that to still be appearing
over here we're gonna get server errors
it's just not gonna work out very well
so what's gonna happen is if you delete
the note that you're already selected we
want to just deselect everything and
kind of reset the state there however if
the note that you delete I say I have
let's just say I have this one selected
right here let's say oh no better yet
let's say I have this one selected okay
this is the third note in the list if I
delete the first note in the list now
there's only two notes in the list and
if there's only two notes in the list
and I have the third one selected then
the third index doesn't exist anymore so
we're gonna get errors so what we're
doing here is we're trying to account
for that specific problem so that's why
this state does selected note index
minus one okay that's why we're doing
that so then we're gonna say the index
is this dot state dot selected note
index minus one so yeah so now we have
the note which is the current note minus
one the state notes the state dot
selected note in
X minus 1 and then we also have to pass
the index because that is the second
argument to the Select Note function
here and that is simply the state does
selected no index minus 1 okay go
through that so we'll put a colon here
since we're still inside of the ternary
operator and you know else if this dot
state dot notes dot length is not
greater than 1 well what that means is
we have no more notes so let's go ahead
and basically just copy this just copy
this line right here let's deselect
everything so if we only have one note
in this list and we delete it there's no
more notes so we need to just deselect
everything all right cool alright so now
that we got all that taken care of we
can go ahead go to firebase and delete
our note so we'll say firebase dot fire
store
dot collection I think you guys are
getting used to this part pretty quick
notes is the name of the collection dot
doc we have the the ID I believe let me
just quickly yeah note that ID node ID
and then we will do dot delete which
makes it really easy for us to delete it
it's built in to firebase so all right
so I'll save that but I'm not gonna
click delete yet because we still have
to go if we look at our sidebar item we
are in fact calling the delete note and
we're passing note as the parameter here
but in sidebar we're only logging still
so we need to save this stuff props dot
delete note we need to pass the note so
we'll accept note as the argument here
and I think that's gonna do it for us
for deleting notes so let's test it out
let's say I select this note and then
let's say I delete the note that I have
selected here let's see what happens
when I when I do this cool so I had a
note selected I deleted the one that I
had selected and now nothing is selected
that's perfect that's exactly what we
wanted to happen
now let's select this note and delete
the one underneath it and see if this
one stays selected let's see what
happens it sort of worked but it also
didn't because this is selected here but
our react quill component broke when
that happened so it's our state is
correct but we have to fix something in
our react quill component for this to
work properly okay so after a little
experimenting I believe I found the
problem that we had with where we were
getting that error and the reason why we
were getting that error I believe is
because we are not removing the so let
me get rid of this sorry so we were not
removing the note that we're deleting
from the notes state at all so we need
to do that so what we need to say is
underneath here we'll just go ahead and
do that really quick actually I will
make this asynchronous so I'll say async
and then I will say here underneath the
note index I will await this not set
state and I'm going to set the whoops at
the notes estate notes equal to notes
dot filter and we just want to return
all of the notes except for the note
that we're passing in right here so
we're just gonna say note stuff filter
and for each note we want every single
know where a note doesn't where note
does not equal note and let's see if
that fixes our problem here notes is not
defined line 87 and that's supposed to
be this wait see this is we this does
state this does state dot notes cool all
right let's see if this fixes our
problem so I'll select this note and
then I'll delete the one before it and
we do not get the error that's that's
actually great so that makes some of
this code a little bit
I guess pointless because what we were
trying to do is if I come back in here
and select this note what I was trying
to be able to do is have this note
selected
and then if I were to delete this note I
would want this note to stay selected so
if I come back up here delete it you can
see that it's no longer selected anymore
and that's perfectly fine the reason why
that's happening is because we're
changing the work we're updating the
state beforehand before this if
statement but what I want you guys to do
since this is an intermediate level
tutorial I want you guys to figure out
how to fix that problem and you can
clone the repository and figure out how
to fix it and then you know if you want
to post in the comments that you fixed
it and share with others how you fixed
it absolutely please do that but I'm not
gonna fix that in this tutorial I do I
did want to lead you leave you guys with
a little bit of homework and I think
this problem is going to be perfect for
you guys so I'm gonna leave you with
that I'm also going to leave you with a
little bit of extra homework afterwards
as well so let's go ahead and move on to
the next function this is actually going
to be inside of our editor component
which we do not have the ability yet to
update our titles so we need to do that
so what we will do is inside of the
render let's go ahead and add a few more
elements to our return inside of our
editor J's file so let's quickly come up
to the top of our editor container here
and let's create a border color icon and
inside of the opening tag we'll give it
a class name that we will set equal to
classes dot edit icon whoops all right
so we have the Edit icon and below this
will create an input and inside of the
opening tag will add some props here or
not really props since this is a
standard HTML element but you get what
I'm saying so class name classes dot
title input and then underneath that
we'll have a placeholder which will be a
plain string and we'll say note title
Dada
of value which will be this state title
whoops this state title so if this DA
state title exists we'll use the turn
ternary operator then we'll go ahead and
say this state title otherwise we'll
just do an empty string and then we'll
have a non change function on change and
the on change will
oops automatically get past the event
which we will pass to our own function
called this to update title this update
title and we will pass a target value to
that and underneath update body we'll go
ahead and create our Update title
function so update title you can see
we're passing the text in so txt and for
update title what we want to do is we
basically want to do exactly what we did
with update body so let's say a weight
let's go ahead and add a sink here oops
oh my gosh okay a sink we want to update
we want to await this dot set state the
chunk of state that we are updating is
the title so it'll be title and we'll
set that equal to txt and once that gets
done we will call this top update so it
will also have a D bounce effect as well
so let's see what happens if I come over
here let me just make this a little
smaller make this a little bigger okay
you can see there's this input here now
when I come in here I can highlight it
and instead of two I'll put like two two
two and you can see it updates the title
as we were expecting expecting it to so
let's go through and test everything so
let's create a new note I'm going to
call this test Note one just for the
heck of it I submit the note it's
automatically selected here you can see
I have a typo so I'm going to fix that I
go in here to edit my note title and it
correctly edits the note title
in here add some text and say hello this
is working and then you can see it
updates here I'll click this note it now
selects this note let's say I don't want
all three twos here I just want to put
this as a test hit updates here I can
come back over here and let's just say
you know replace this with text that
make sense
testing the body cool so that updates
and now I'm going to delete this note so
I delete it it deselects everything I
delete this note now we have no notes
and the app appears to be working
perfectly so final note test yep it's
all working as expected so this is a
fully functional Evernote clone
application where you can take your own
notes and everything and as you remember
there was a a small thing that you guys
could fix on your own if you'd like to
which is the selecting so if I have
multiple notes and I delete one of the
notes keep the one that's selected
selected instead of deselecting it you
know explicitly please try to fix that
if you are interested in furthering your
abilities within react that would be a
great exercise for you another great
exercise for you is to go watch the
other tutorial that I have in the
description which is for an instant
messaging application in which it goes
over how to create user accounts so
you'll be able to create user accounts
and then what I think would be
interesting is for you to take this
Evernote application and create user
accounts so that a user can sign in and
they can have their own notes and then
another user can sign in and they won't
have access to any other notes but their
own so its user based so I highly
recommend you try watching that tutorial
and then afterwards come back to this
tutorial when you're done with it and
try to combine what you learned in the
previous tutorial and in this tutorial
and see if you can add the ability to
have users with this Evernote clone
alright guys I really hope you enjoyed
this tutorial and
know that it went pretty quickly and I
know that it was probably a little bit
confusing but there are certain parts
where it's good that it's confusing if
that makes sense it's a little
challenging and you can stop you can
pause and you can think deeply about
these topics and when you do get it it's
you get a good sense of satisfaction
that you learned something new so I
really hope you did enjoy if you did
please give me a like subscribe to my
channel and I will see you guys in the
next tutorial